natürlich das kitz und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen minecraft
video
heute gehen wir wieder auf einen ts der
euch bekannt sein dürfte und zwar auf
mein ts und wir werden wieder ein paar
zuschauer überraschen das habe ich schon
mal ein paar videos gemacht drei folgen
bisher falls er die noch nicht kennt
schuldig die gerne an ist aber so eine
schnapsidee dich mal hatte und ihr euch
gut gefallen hat so wird sein dass man
hier auf den ts darauf also es läuft so
ab
wegen jetzt drauf und dann werden wir
sehen was passiert erstmal gucken
welchen stellen wir gehen oktober
entscheiden
da ist aber noch musik dort drinnen das
heißt eventuell läuft jetzt komplette
musik war ein genie
ich musste ihnen einfach raus alle
probieren sie das mal aus ok hallo hallo
was geht bei euch allen meine weltraum
persönlichkeit oder wie hot eher wie die
flügel von the dome jungs wie sieht's
aus hat der bock auf eine runde spielen
du bist kratzen freund bestimmt das leid
ich tut es dich ein bisschen unter
pilgern damit er nicht so kratz und dann
lass uns doch mal loslegen jetzt
internet mails schon ich würde
vorschlagen
wir spielen ohne bett wars bett
wsj com schreibt eure namen in game
alles klappt ihr beiden alles klar
jetzt kommen aufkommen auch wenn er kein
prima habe mir ein paar die in weit den
front kraft front kraft eher wie eine
flüchtlinge die nur im cockpit den
herstellt andere luca mit 221 okay es
wird richtig richtig schnell folge ist
ein problem wie wenig ärger machen
warte jetzt rein wieso uns einfach nur
eine firma 3 die stadt denn ganz schnell
ach steht man die wären aber so schnell
voll ist es auf ribery besser wenn meine
ich nicht extra für die aufnahme premium
holen aber wenn es wenn dass er vorhat
das krass aber sie jetzt das muss muss
nicht sein
ja okay und dann passt das alles cool du
nicht dass du dann dann wegen einer
unterwegs das ist nicht der sinn der
sache
dr sechseinhalb stunden später dann wird
es wahrscheinlich nicht belohnt sondern
empire liam noch nie gespielt
meinst du wie ist das front kannst du
die map ich hole mal noch beck stick und
pix und rasch und einfach mal durch mit
tabletten so first try front ein mikro
ist dass er am übersteuern kannst du es
ändern als würdest du so auf mich
einwirken dass ich ein anderer mensch
wert
wenn nicht ist auch kein stress lassen
anprobieren in die mitte wir werden nur
wenn es wirklich schnell hinkriegen kann
es ja irgendwie pegel unterstellen wir
aufnahmegeräte aber wie gesagt kein es
keinen stress wir müssen mal gucken dass
ich mich in der runde formen und den
ländern
okay okay okay ich habe viel gold für
gold zack zack zack zack zack snyders ok
vier gold hab ich geschafft
davon habe ich mir erst mal den es darf
gut haben wir auch noch reisen
wenn ich zum zweiten hätte könnte ich
mir doch wartete er liegt 1 oder nimmst
du da ich halt nicht immer noch 1
gebraucht
deswegen hat es genau gepasst du hast
ein bett schon geholt alter krass man
von wem und junge übertreibt dann live
sehr gut
ach ja leute ich hab's ganz vergessen
die vorstellungsrunden stelle ich mal
kurz vor
also wie heiße wir heute genannt werden
und wie alt und müsste morgen mit in
unser bett mit alter schwer ich bin
nicht getroffen
ok 14 und luca und und der andere ist
front ich bin ja oder und kräfte immer
frontdisplay 13 jahre alt und ja
in dem slum hätten nice und ich bin hier
gerade die du zum killen
ich habe ich habe richtig gewesen
ok solche soft blau weiß blau gehabt wo
ist ins bett ist es ein turm drin ist
irgendwie so drin ganz hinten ganz mit
dem haus okay okay ich glaube ich
einfach mal gepackt blaue hoch bitte
nicht unter schießen wir da drüben die
anderen teams am turn teams an wie eine
fluglinie aus den anden und ja komme ich
damit weit ich glaube auch das ist
einfach unten im tor und rinder das
blatt ja kann es sein okay gut dann weiß
ich zumindest wurde das teil ist ja
freund ist auch da okay fand ich
schreien trainerschein
alter schwede geht mir jetzt gut hinein
farthmann alter schwede war war wo meine
sonne ist gespielt von mir jetzt kommen
wir einem etwas gilt sich halter der
fasching ist g12 eisen gut gut bei dem
gut wie sieht's bei euch das wollen wir
mal ist unser bett eigentlich eingebaut
jana sehr gut
super ich denke dann denke ich nämlich
nicht
dieses bett einzubauen gut dass es
zuverlässige partner auf dieser welt
gibt
ältere ja und das war ein geiler welthit
dass meine welt ad donau pörnbach upside
down hole gold wenn man erstmal einen
bogen
ich versuche auf ok wurde abgebaut ich
hab mal auf grün
die einzigen außer uns die noch im bett
am schiff mann der ihr egal ob jetzt da
wir zumindest mal die kreyenborg ich
glaube er kommt her der kommt her und er
nicht ich weiß es nicht
naja ok der kampagne der kampf gut also
dann muss noch einer oder was dessen
unterhalten da eine blaue den hole ich
mir gerade er war dennoch das da hinten
kommen noch die letzten blauen und dann
können wir zum grünen ihr könnt ihr so
lange schon belagern sehr gut und sagt
ich springe einfach runter ich habe
immer noch so nochmal rein gedrückt
heißt es runter gefallen ist okay gut
wer jetzt noch einen gegner wie sieht's
aus
dieses grüne crypt du bist du bist
heruntergefallen und günstig ungünstig
ok luca ist da vorne und belagerte schon
ein bisschen versucht die im schach zu
halten nicht zu sterben sehr gut
hinterher kommt ich hätte ich
wahrscheinlich hätte ich alles gut alles
gut alles gut nicht ständig stämme mit
ok ich gebe zu ich habe sieben gold ich
habe erstens dafür
ok jetzt elf gold- und dann passt das
auch ssl für golden roberto contini okay
ist noch eins und ja es war krass okay
ich habe jetzt 13 geändert erholen oder
bringt dies nicht auf der map ich glaube
übrigens robert hatte ich doch froh
darüber dass hat die dümmste dümmste
dümmste entscheidung sie durch die durch
die durch alte späte mich soweit
ausnahmen können okay was kann man
machen
wie ok dann hole ich mal von stärke
trank sagt stärke trank und eine
rettungsplattform beenden
wie lege ich mal auf die drei mit der
picke gewaltiger denken zu silber wie
sieht's aus
habt ihr habt ihr die hatte auch einige
wochen warten
das kommt natürlich dazu wie sieht's aus
okay er hat das brett ich hole mir die
komplette hier seiner und bei air fliegt
jetzt doktoranden kurz dann ist ohne
geworden und chuck sehr schön leute ich
weiß jetzt gar nicht wieder aufgenommen
weil wir davor schon so ewig so wie
gerade eben schon
ja okay ich will seine branche dabei ich
weiß wirklich nicht wer die ohne waren
verzieht kurz war tut es mir leid wie
eine fluglinie den beilagen produziert
dankeschön an euch luca und front oder
zuschauer wir sehen uns beim nächsten
video wieder rein macht es gut und schau